hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope everything is fine wherever you are
this is spanish grandmaster pepe
and i welcome you to this class
insane in the endgame so first of all
uh please let me know if everything's
fine regarding audio so you can hear me
you can listen to me and then we are
ready to start the class
so see already some people in the chat
out there in the youtube channel dan
sridhar and uh some people are joining
so just let me know that you can hear me
sounds great
okay thanks a lot so what are we gonna
do today
well we're gonna check some artistic
end games from gurgaon it's a
georgian composer and reti and
we have time we have to we're gonna
check
the game between carlson and levon
ironian from norway chess
where we can actually find as well a
really interesting
end game and this game means a lot
because actually
mac is the first loss for magnus carlsen
in three years
with the white pieces so
pretty amazing and uh this was achieved
by levon aronian super grandmaster from
armenia
oh people from brazil here too so from
everywhere this is nice
so the first end game is one of my
favorites
this is a composition from gurgaon it
says
where white to play
so it's a crazy position i know it's not
maybe the best
puzzle to to start to warm up but uh
this way you will get you will you will
start
uh with a difficult puzzle and
then you will have to concentrate a lot
so why to move i mean
if we promote it's somehow we have to
promote that pawn right otherwise
i mean black is a two-piece app two
pieces up
so we're in real trouble right so
let me know what you think about this
position and uh what would you play here
with the white pieces something
we will discover some things so just
give me some candidate moves
so hi matthias mathias from denmark
i just came back from sweden i was
flying to copenhagen and then taking the
train
from there to sweden uh but i actually
had a lot of troubles
in the police control because now the
derma is banned for spanish people
but i was traveling to sweden so that's
why they allowed me to enter
as you guys know the situation is a bit
crazy everywhere but in spain
even more you know so
yeah so what do you play here with the
white pieces you go h8
just queens or what
yeah that's that's right so the first
move that has to come to our minds is h8
right
so h8 queen but it has a problem
it's not losing but it's not winning why
what do we play here with the black
pieces
and i guarantee you that after this
variation we're going to land a lot yeah
rook g6
that's the best move for black and the
problem is that if we take on g6 now
bishop h8
and even though you managed to take on
e7 with the boob two bishops
and the passport on the a file black is
not gonna lose
so but we have an idea here after rook
g6
so there's one move that we don't lose
the queen
so what is this move we always shoot
truss in facundo you know facundo is the
f
pawn so what should we play here after
rook g6 check
there's only one move to play here with
the white pieces that's right then
that's right
push push kara tough name for me
yvonne that's great f6 but then we
realize
that after rook takes f6 now we are in
the same situation as before because now
if
white takes on e7 then rookie six and
then we
more or less transpose to the same
position
but after rook f6 white can try
king d5 and now you play
rook f5 again white has an
option here not to lose the queen
this move is e5
now black takes on e5 king c4
rook e4 check again white cannot take on
e4 because
black just captures the queen so d4
rook takes d4 king b3
rook d3 and now c3
only move rook takes e3 and king a2
and now you cannot go i mean you're
gonna go rook c2 because there is kinae
one just winning
but now black wins this game with the
move
b3 now it doesn't matter where you go
for example you go to b1 there is rook
c1 check
you take on a1 there is checkmate on c1
and if you take on a3 there is b2
quintex e3 and now what do you play here
with the black pieces
this is a very beautiful variation it's
a really insane puzzle
but we are not done we still have a lot
to understand in this position what do
you play here
you play queen b1
yeah b1 knight of course that's great so
b1 knight
this is a check and then you capture the
queen and then actually
black wins the game so this is a really
nice puzzle
so this means that black wins in this
position but you guys should have
learned
something after all this way
right because white is always trying to
have to
to to hide the dick in but it's not
possible
but let's see if you guys learned
something
after this variation so what's the idea
then for white let's see so
if somebody's able to to spot this
because it's really insane it's just
very very beautiful
it's very beautiful if we don't take the
rook
yeah but i mean if you promote an h8 we
just saw
that black wins so
h8 bishop this is too much yeah
if you promote the bishop i mean
okay black's a piece a piece up right so
you can do whatever you want here even
king b7 should be winning here but no h8
bishop is not the solution
so h8 bishop doesn't work
it's just a piece down for black so we
are completely lost in that position
and take on b4 first well you take on b4
this is very interesting but i guess you
can take now h8
rook g6 f6 rook f6 king d5
rook f5 e5 rook takes king c4 and now
rook c5
even easier for black
right so it's not rook takes before
but you are trying to understand
something
f a f f six first well f6 the problem is
just
rook takes h7 right so basically black
is threatening to capture that pawn
if black captures this one we have to
say goodbye
to the game so no f6 doesn't work
rook takes eight seven and of the end of
the story for us
yes there's somebody in the chat who
spotted the solution
already so
during all these paths there was a
moment
where we would love to have a square for
the kin
and this square is a4
imagine after all this variation with a
rook on c3
just playing king a4
and then there will be no more checks
right so
that's right rk8 great
rook a8 that's the move
this this this puzzle is just so so
amazing
so kintex a8 h8
rook g6 f6 rook takes
king d5 rooker 5 k4
oh sorry e5 rook takes e5 kin c4
rookie 4 d4 takes kim b3
rook d3 c3 rook takes c3
and king a4
we got this square to hide our king and
now
this bishop is just falling
so next move is going to be queen takes
e8 and actually is going to be checkmate
to the black king pretty amazing right
so but i have for you one question it's
a crazy line
i know i have for you one question what
happens if black plays
key b7
what happens if black says you know what
i just pass
you know i just pass you know keem b7
and what do you play
you just promote now h8
or what because if you promote let's say
h8 just again rook g6
f6 and now rook f6 skin d5
and now bishop f7
because now there's no c6 square for the
king
so after king b7 take the bishop you say
take the bishop no because of rook takes
h7
so what's the idea that's right mr puska
that's right rook b8 kin takes and now
you can promote again h8 rook g6
king d5 sorry f6
rook takes f6 king d5 and now
the bishop is pinned this is the key
right the king has to be on the back
rank or the wise bishop
f7 would be winning right as in the
variation that we just saw with the king
of b7
so that's why we are still in the same
kind of variation
now rook f5 e5 takes rook
e4 d4 and again we are able
to hide our kin on the a4 square and
given the fact that this bishop is
pinned now black is going to win after
taking this guy on e8
right so
pretty nice end game let's check another
one
this time from red you guys know the
previous week we just saw some puzzles
from bretty
but had two more for you so first one
this position black is about to promote
but white is a rook and a bishop app
so what should we play here with the
white pieces just taking account that
now black is threatening to capture your
rook
from f4 to g3 so we're gonna pay
attention to this
right so let's all think about this
position
and just give me some candidate moves
and this is the way we learn yeah you
you give me some candidate moves we try
to understand them we analyze the
variations and then
we learn something from the variations
that don't work and then we find the
proper solution
it's white to move that's right rook d3
somebody else is
proposing another move rook d3 check
something else you want to go rook g1 no
right because after rook g1 just e1
promoting
so basically i think rook d3 is the only
move right
but it's not that easy as it looks
because now after kidney one
what do you move black's plan is
rather simple black wants to go key in
f2 and e1
so bishop g4 somebody's saying here well
bishop g4
now you play king f1
and there is no way of stopping e1 right
you take well you play rook f3 then king
g2 and now
next move is going to be e1
so no bishop g4 looks
it doesn't look winning right so keen f1
sorry
and now you take on e2 again king takes
and then f3 f2 f1
basically this is just a draw so
somebody is proposing they're just keen
c2
well now i just play king f2 and what's
your idea
after ken f2 because i mean i'm just
promoting next move so basically you are
forced to go rook d2 in this position
and now i just go f3
basically you have no moves for example
you go in d3
i just go king and next move
e1 you are forced to take actually on e2
so king c2 doesn't work so we set
rook rook d3 kin e1
and now it's white to move so keen c2
doesn't work
bishop g4 doesn't work
this is another beautiful puzzle yeah it
took me like 20 minutes to solve it you
know
because whenever i i bring you a class
guys so i i i prefer just to to do it on
my own so i can try to explain you
better
the lines right not only with the
computer it's too boring yeah it's just
it's just so much happiness when you
solve a puzzle yeah in
the real chess board
so somebody is proposing rook f3 you got
more ideas
or not look at three
okay rook f3 is the move here so just
stopping key in f2
but now there are different questions so
what happens we have to analyze what
happens if black plays
kindly one or kindy two basically these
are the only legal moves for white in
this position
for black in this position sorry so
let's start with kim d1
what do you play what do you play
after kindy one if you go rook d3 you've
done nothing right i just go back to
iwan
and
so ralph
ralph found out the solution well bishop
f1
i just queen and after rook d3 just
queen d2
and then that's no mate so bishop f1
doesn't work just e1 and then rook d3
just queen d2
and then you gotta take on d2 and that's
a dead draw right so
no no bishop f1
so if bishop f1 is not working
that's right bishop g4 as ralph said
and our friend bina jack being a jack
and ralph they say bishop g4 what's the
idea well
you promote now there's rook d3
checkmate and basically
black cannot do anything else i mean if
black goes king d2 now you just play
rook f2 you pin this pawn you capture
this pawn
you win this game you get out of the
playing hole
you go and make a party
so that's why king d1 doesn't work
because this beautiful
move bishop g4 so then
there's one more move for black here in
this position just kind d2
and now what do we play after king d2
because now bishop g4 doesn't make any
sense right he want to screen
the screens and then we are even losing
okay so arthur
proposes one great move yeah now bishop
f1
that's right guys because now if black
promotes
with e1 then rook d3 is just checkmate
and if black takes on if on f1 sorry
rook takes f1 ki e3 king c2 f3
and now you give me one more move here
for white
still not that easy this position
so mr 72 is asking what happens after
rook takes f4 sorry rook at 3 kindy 2
rook f4 i just grabbed i just queen yeah
so bishop f1 we are in this position
sorry
king c2 f3 and now king d1
you sure about this done fraud being a
jack arthur
are you sure about this move kindy one
everybody's saying kindy one
you we were all making a party guys
after your win you know now we cannot
celebrate you know
this just happens to me so much so much
times you know i mean so many times
i was about to win the spanish national
championship like in
two clear occasions i was leading in the
last round
and then my friends had prepared me a
nice party in my hometown
with a vip room in san diego tech and
then i managed to lose all those two
games
and then there was no party you know so
here there's no party after your kindly
one
kindy one is a blunder
because now f2 and what do you play
you cannot move the king because of kini
2 if you move the rook
there is kin f3 and then next move king
g2
attacking the rook you go rook f1 i just
go back to e3
i don't go to g2 of course because there
is key e2 and then
black loses the pawn but then just go
back to e3 and then this is a draw
incredibly
so kindy one is a blunder actually
so no kin no kindy one so instead we
play
what do we play instead
i like draws
yeah not that easy
rookie one that's great guys rook e1
this is just the solution
yeah and after kin f4 we just bring the
king
now f2 rook f1 king of three and now we
play kindy two this is a different story
because now the rook is not on h1 and if
black goes
let's say kin f2 we just bring the kin
right king d2 let's say king g3 and now
king e3
f2 we just pin the pawn with rookie 2.
okay so last puzzle before we check
magnus carlsen versus levon ironian game
so so so this end game is a well-known
end game this is another composition
by reddy so black is going in this
direction
right and now it's white to move of
course otherwise black will capture the
rook yeah
so
now we have three options
rook d3 rook d1 and rook d2 sorry
rook d3 rook d2 and rook d1
rook d2 so where would you go
rook d2 to lose a tempo are you sure you
don't want to prefer
to be far away from the king
hello to the people that are coming from
the chess 24
side as well you guys can write in the
chat and also paying attention to you
guys
so rook t1 rook d2 rook d3
is not the best idea right because
now kinifor just wins the tempo so let's
try to understand what happens
for those who said rook d1 which are
some people actually
again blunder rook d1 it's a big blunder
but it's it's a tough puzzle yeah so
let's try to understand why because now
black plays d4
and now what do you want to play with
the white pieces i guess you want to
play
king d7 right but then black doesn't go
kidney four
of course because of the kidney for just
kinsey six d3
king c5 kidney three king c4
d2 king c3 and white grabs the pawn
but instead after king d5 after kindy
seven black goes
king d5 opposition opposition is so
important you can tell that to ali
desafirusa right
he lost a very uh well
um easy end game for him
actually against magnus carson
opposition is a very important important
concept right
of course he was shaking because he was
low on time you know and this can happen
to anyone
and it's so easy to talk from outside
the ball right so always with the
deepest respect to the players
but uh indeed he he just loses he just
lost a
a very easy end game against magnus
carson in norway chess
so king d7 and now you go king c7 you
still
keep the opposition with king c5 and
there's no way
that white can make any progress now if
white goes king b7
now you can go king c4 because white's
idea
is to put pressure on this pawn from the
other side
and same applies if white goes skinny
seven you go
kidney five kin f7 now you can go kidney
four because
this skin must put pressure on this pawn
from this side
all right so that's why
what we do is we just lose the tempo
with rook d2 and after
d4 what do we play
okay jonas gave me one move here
somebody else
that's right it's just a waiting move
not rook d1 that's right that's great so
now we got the opposition
so after king d5 king d7
and now there's no way that black can
stop
either either king c6 or kidney 6
after kidney five keen c6 after king c5
kidney six and then we are able to put
pressure on the d4 pawn and now black
goes keen c4 where do you go to c6 or to
e6
don't blunder here yeah
so now where do we go after king c4
or king d6
e6 or d6 both of them work the idea is
to put pressure from this side of the
board don't go to c6 otherwise
we just we just draw the gain again keen
c6 is just that draw
okay so king d6 or kidney six doesn't
matter d3 and now kidney five that's the
idea
king c3 guinea for t2 and kidney three
and then we just grab this
pawn and again we are so happy and we
just win the game
okay guys so these were the three
puzzles that i had ready for this
class i think they are quite nice so for
the next insane in the end game class
we can actually check mark like this i
will prepare some nice puzzles for the
next class but now
we're going to check magnus carlsen game
versus 11 aronian from norway chess
because the end game is also quite
interesting
and uh this is a very very important
game
because you know how much time magnus
carlsen was without
losing a single game with the white
pieces you guys know about the straight
right 125 games without losing
almost i think 800 days or something
so two years something like this but you
know how much time
was he without losing a single game with
the white pieces
know three years you know i cannot win
even for two weeks in a row
i cannot wait even for two weeks in a
row
so let's see what happened in this game
so 93 from magnus carlsen
d5 from lebanon t4 knight f6 and c4 the
queens
the queen's gambit now e6
and knight c3 of course there are other
attentives here for white you can go
g3 this is known as the catalan opening
right one of my favorites
knight c3 and now black has several
options to be fair he was in extreme
time pressure when he lost the
opposition
that's right
i mean i agree with you i mean he was
very nervous he was
i'm sure he's playing bullet on on
leeches
or chess24chess.com and he makes a
drawing every game but
the circumstances were pretty different
he was facing the world champion
and he was pretty low on time and he was
very nervous and
he just lost because of the nerves you
know
so here there are different options for
for for for black this is the queen's
gambit decline that's right
bishop b4 we enter in the so-called
drago scene defense
c5 going for the tie rush or semi tow
rush
tyresh is when you take with the pawn
semi tyres is
when you take with the knight and after
e4 knight x is c3
you have more options too here in this
position you can go c6 of course
and after bishop g5 we can go for the
moscow variation of our jetpodpinic
variation
crazy lines and you can also try here
what else
you can try of course a6 which is a
pretty solid line very used nowadays in
the
in the top tournaments and the last
option i guess well do you have many
options knight bd7 but also d takes e4
this is the so-called vienna variation
but instead lemonade goes for the most
natural right bishop e7 mainline on the
queen's gambit decline
and now the two main moves are
bishop f4 or bishop g5
right so you wanna keep this bishop
out of the pawn chain so that's why i
mean before you play e3 you
develop this bishop so this bishop
can hope for a best a better life right
so
c takes d5 instead from magnus carlsen
this is not the main line
but he went for this he takes e5 he
takes e5 and now
bishop f4 okay
so 11 goes for c6 normally black's
black reinforces the center with this
move c6
so d5 is not suffering anymore and now
queen c2 from magnus carlsen
what do you think is the idea behind
queen c2
exactly call spot structure
so what do you think is the idea behind
queen c2
why white goes for queen c2 instead of
e3
what's the worst piece for black in this
position too
normally it's the bishop on c8 because
doesn't enjoy proper diagonals right
maybe long castle that's that's a good
that's a nice idea
but there's another idea behind queen c2
it's even
easier stop bishop f5 you are more than
right akash
because the best square for this bishop
is f5 by far
on g4 can be hit by a knight on e5 so
basically
just uh white improves the knight by
winning a tempo
but f5 is nice you cannot go bishop f5
straight away because of queen b3 and
now
b7 suffers a lot right so that's why
black goes
c6 and now let's say if you you go e3
then bishop f5 now black is ready to
meet queen b3
with queen b6 d5 is well protected so
there's no problem for black in this
position
so that's right queen c2 is normally
played
to stop bishop f5 but let's say
you want to insist so how do we sit
in sit sir insist by playing
bishop f5 i mean we can play a move
that helps to that purpose
so what do we play here with the black
pieces guys that's right
g6 now this is why all the moves behind
theory they have a meaning right g6
it looks like it weakens uh the key
inside right because now h6 and f6
are weaknesses right but
black wants to go bishop f5 and it's
very important to play g6 now because if
you go
e3 let's say sure castle then white goes
e3 and after g6
what can we play here with the white
pieces
yeah exactly when you play g6 then the
dark squares are pretty pretty
pretty weak right unless there is a
bishop on g7 who covers
those squares that's right so bishop d3
and now bishop f5 is just not possible
and this is
this is known and a better position as a
better position for white right so
that's why you're going to play
g6 immediately so this is what lemon
aronian did and magnus calzone went for
e3
now bishop f5 anyway and bishop d3 from
magnus kelson
bishop takes d3 queen takes e3 and
knight b
to d7 from lebanon so i want to ask you
guys
what do you think that are the most
typical plans for white
in this position
there are different plans of course
different ideas you can give me
all of them or maybe some of them that's
right minority attack
is one of them what's the minority
attack well when there are
four pawns here and you got
three you can you can start trying
an attack on the queen side and this is
why it's called minority attack
just because black has more points you
know it's nothing subtle it's nothing
special
that's right so one of the plans is just
to bring this pawn to b5 this can be
done by playing rook b1
it black stops that by playing a5 you
can try a3 b4 and b5
and what do i what do you achieve by
playing b5 well
if black takes on b5 then d5 is gonna be
awake in the long term right you can put
a lot of pressure on this guy
by bringing a queen to b3 in the future
and
if black doesn't take on c6 you're going
to take on c6
with the white pieces and after b take
c6 c6 is going to become a weakness
as uh somebody's saying they're in the
chat
exactly done c6 can be easily attacked
in the future
by doubling rooks on the c5 and also c5s
becomes a weak square for example
maneuvers like knight a4 and knight c5
are very interesting in this kind of
positions
right what else can we play here with
the white pieces
well of course you can try to go for
some e4 ideas as somebody said
and magnus carlsen here played extremely
aggressive with the move
h4 i couldn't believe when i was
watching this
game i was actually doing commentary for
norway chess in spanish
an h4 really aggressive maybe trying to
go for long castle in some position
also intend to go for ah5
and uh what about exploding kingside
weakness
that's right this is what magnus carlsen
tried to
to do in this game he went for age four
and magnus carlsen
uh i mean he was already er
i mean he already won the tournament by
this point because he had another
advantage
so probably he wanted to have some fun
in the last game against
levon ironian i don't know if you guys
have seen the
interview from lebanon now of course
armenia and azerbaijan are in a very
tough conflict so maybe not the best
time for levin to play chess
so but he actually played a fantastic
game
on a fantastic tournament actually he is
now again back in the
i think it's tops number six in the
world let me just check guys
so in this beautiful website 2700 chess
dot com
yeah so lemonade is now current number
six in the world with a rating of 27
81 increasing 40 14 points so
pretty nice and you know after
all but ha all bad things that have
happened to him in the last in the last
months
i mean i was happy to to see him just
playing a a a great tournament
so h4 so what do you play now with the
black pieces is
h5 a threat you want to stop h5 by
playing h5 yourself or h6 or do you just
want to pass
and you just go short castle or any
other move what would you play here
with the black pieces
yeah seems standard now this h4 ideas i
mean lemon ironian himself has played
his age for ideas in many occasions for
example
against the gruntful in many many games
you go h5 well i'm not so sure about
this h5 move
i know it's the easiest way to deal with
h5 so you just forget about
h5 from from white right so you just
want to keep playing but i'm not so sure
about this move
because now g6 becomes more weak and
also the g5 square
but of course it's more than playable
yeah 86 it's another option but i just
don't like it you know because
you're never gonna be able to go short
castle in this position
so i think what level neronia did is
more than natural he went for a5 just
you know ignoring magnus calls and ideas
because now
h5 probably is just a bad move because
of knight takes h5 right
and the king is still in the center so
there's no point so now
i mean you are you open the h file but
this skin is still in the center
so probably it's not that dangerous for
black very interesting of course for
white but
i think this is more than than okay for
black
and in this game magnus carlsen went for
king f5 king f1 sorry kin f5
that would be a great jump but no key in
f1
magnus calcium idea is probably to go g3
followed by
king g2 and then this skin is kind of
safe
on the g2 square because if you go short
castle now this h4 doesn't make any
sense right
you would love to have this pawn on h3
on h4
well doesn't make any sense knife knight
knife f5 all right guys so a5
kin of one and a4 from level and roni he
wants to go a3 in this position
so that's why magnus stopped that by
playing a3 himself
and now queen b6 from level ironia
what do you play here with the white
pieces this is an important question
right now
i think it doesn't look like a critical
position it looks like you can play
basically
whatever you want in this position just
protecting the the betas
the b2 square but it's not that easy
well the idea with a5 is just to grab
some space on the on the queen side and
also
provoke this a3 by magnus carlsen now
the b3 square is going to be
important as you're going to see in this
game
so what do you play now well you got two
options or yeah two
decent options queen c2 or rook b1 you
gotta choose
you're gonna choose one of them who
votes for queen c2 who votes for
rook b1
whoa
so queen c2
y rook b1 blunders upon no you don't
blunder anything because bishop a3 is
just not possible the rook on b1 is
well protected from these two pieces
so queen c2 but there's a reason behind
that why to play queen z2
knight d1 is too passive oh i just shot
it
yeah knight d1 is too passive right you
don't want to move this knight to d1
knight is controlling e4
fantastic squares also putting pressure
on a4
the problem with rook b1 is queen a6
because now the end game is more than 5
for black remember that white was trying
to put some pressure here trying to
attack black skin now there's no attack
without queens
and black is perfectly fine after
trading queens
uh bold move by people to use the green
screen to overlay a green screen
background
no because i'm recording some video
series guys
so i need to but that's right i could
use the
green screen as well for this show i'll
try to do this for
for the next for the next show by the
way i can tell you but in two hours
i mean 22 hours and 20 minutes i'll be
streaming in the
twitch channel of the saint louis chess
club
so we're going to move there for banta
blitz so you guys will be able to play
against me in chess 24.
we'll be using this sidejust24 because i
work there usually
i just can't play there so i'll send you
the link
in twitch where you can challenge me
preferably three minute games okay
all right so queen er
so queen c2 from magnus carson he
doesn't want to trade queens and now
lemon lemonade finally decides to go for
h5
which i'm not so sure but okay of course
as i was telling you before this is
completely understandable right
so bishop g5 from magnus carlsen sure
castle
yeah i know i hit pretty hard did my
keyboard you know once i was living in
germany
i i lived in germany for three years and
then
there was some night i was just trying
to write an email you know and
i'm just you know so clumsy i just hit
the keyboard with
so much strength you know that the
neighbors
came to complain they were asking me if
i was moving the furniture
from one place to another i was just
writing an email when i told them they
couldn't believe it
all right and uh here after
shortcastle95
magnus galson starts with his talking
ideas
now what do you think is the idea behind
this knight e5
well first of all you want to trade on
d7 and then take on e7
but after lebanon plays rook e8
now we always have to keep an eye
on this g6 square right
because now if white takes on g6 at
least
there's some danger i think it's not
enough but it was definitely extremely
interesting for white
you got some ideas like rook h3 rook g3
in the end
the engine says this is just fine for
black after rook h3 you just take on b2
and if you play something like rook b1
in this position just queen d a to play
rook g8 at some point i think white
uh only has a draw by repetition with
queen h6 and queen g6 right
so this is why magnus carlsen didn't go
for knight g6 he was not happy with the
draw and then
he took on f6 of course now black is
forced to take with the knight on f6
and rook h3 by magnus carlsen
the idea is quite clear he wants to go
rook g3 and then
make up a boom on g6 and just wins the
game so what do we play here with the
black pieces a tough moment for
levon aronian what are your candidate
moves
yeah s3 g4 probably that's pretty slow
but
definitely it's an idea too just to open
some files
on the key inside right
kin8h7 kin887 you just blundered your f7
pawn right
knight e4 that's an idea definitely
and what else king h7 justice pawn
is hanging so you cannot go for this i
understand you want to protect g6 but
then f7 is also a key square
a focal point king g7
not so sure about this move because
after rook g3 now even rook takes g6 is
actually a threat
rook g6 pawn takes queen takes and then
mate on f7
or yeah on f7 with the queen or with the
knight depending
where you go so
tough moment for leonardo but he solved
it pretty
pretty good actually with the move queen
b3 again if you go bishop g6 well now
the sacrifice is very very interesting
takes
takes and this knight is just hanging on
f6 right now so that's why
d6 may not be the best idea in this
position
knight e4 this is the other move that
you guys suggested
it's interesting but now rook f3 is very
annoying because again
pressure on f7 pressure pressure
pressure
you go rook fade is knight d7
bye bye sayonara baby
so the best move was queen b3 and this
is what uh lemon ironian did
of course magnus doesn't want to trade
queen so he
he goes for queen b1 keeping an eye on
this g6 square and also intend to go now
rook g3
so what do we play again
now it's another important moment for
black
what's up marcos how are you doing all
cool
where are you pepe i am in ibiza right
now it's a beautiful island
in the east of spain and just moved here
when the pandemic started it's a nice
place for summer
and also to work you know so
just here my next tournament will be
like the 31st of this month
so in 11 days actually it will be a
rapid tournament
so i'm so looking forward to play a real
otb chess tournament right
so what do we play here with the black
pieces again you saw the idea
before but now it's it's the right
moment to go for this idea
i'm telling you you saw this idea before
so any ideas guys any candidate mobs
yeah that's right then 94 now we said
before that the problem with knight e4
was rook f3 but now
knight d4 might d2 sorry it's a real
threat
with this fork just winning the game so
this is what lebron ironian played
yeah mobs like b5 this doesn't help to
your position because now after rook g3
you it's really tough to stop like these
ideas uh
sacrificing ideas on g6 right so b5
doesn't improve your position you're
gonna act quickly
and this is what lemonade did knight e4
so now the queen on b1 is not
attacking g6 anymore and after knight
e4 then magnus took on e4
d takes e4 and queen takes
e4 another important moment
important sorry
so what do we play here you have to take
in account that
white is upon up right now so
bishop by f8 it's an option interesting
option
yeah definitely is a decent move more
ideas
i mean this knight is extremely annoying
right so
we wanna kick this knight at least
eliminate it from the board so how do we
do this
bishop f6 this is another idea
that's right and the move that levon
ironian did which is
bishop d6 the idea is just to take on e5
and white has also to remember that the
b2 pawn is under attack right
so bishop d6 bishop f6 same idea
just to take this knight on e5 and then
the king will be more safe
on g8 right only two heavy pieces
attacking this skin
so in the case that
white takes on g6 at some point
he will have only a troll
right if the knight disappears from e5
right
so bishop d6 and now white goes rook g3
and bishop takes e5 pawn takes e5
and now what do you play with the black
pieces
now lebanon didn't want to draw because
now after the move queen takes b2
from level magnus can always take a draw
with
taking on g6 and then perpetual check
right so
but then iran didn't want to take a draw
so he went for a better line
and from here he put a lot of pressure
on magnus carlsen's position
what's the move then this is just a
simple way to
to take the pawn on e5 right just go for
it
forcing moves captures checks and
threats
with this you will solve a lot of
positions
bishop f5 queen b5 check that's right
queen b5 check and then you capture this
one on e5
so king g1 rook takes e5 now black has
taken this one on e5 and then black is a
little bit better
why because now the attack has
disappeared against the black skin
and then your structure is better the
rook on g3 is basically doing nothing
it's like watching a movie in the cinema
this rook should be on d1 right or
something
but on g3 it's basically attacking g6
but only
with two pcs it's not gonna be enough to
create any kind of trouble to black skin
so queen d4 was played by carlson and
now rook d5
queen f6 rook f5 queen d4
and magnus was more than happy with the
drone so after
rook d5 i i'm 100 sure that magnus
cassette will have gone for this queen
f6 just
aiming to go for triple repetition but
lemonade
plays queen e2 putting pressure on f2
and white plays e4
so now it's your turn where do you go
with the rook
rk5 rk5 pretty strange square for the
rook
you normally want to go to open files
right where you can
have some targets so
where do we go with the rook right now
follow the leader leave the leader
follow the leader
follow the leader leave the leader
follow the lead that
exactly done so rook b5 that's a better
square because
b2 is on attack so magnus tries to
protect this pawn and then he plays
passively with the move rook b1
and queen c2 by levon aronian forcing
white to play queen d3
and now queen takes e3 sorry rook c5
queen takes
rook takes and then we reach this end
game where of course is this somebody
who's better in this position it has to
be black
because black has this nice rook on the
seventh rank but still magnus has
a lot of drawing chances in this
position and then he wants to exchange
some pawns by playing b3 also friends
rook
who was very passive now aiming to put
some pressure on the b
file but lebron says you know what i
just don't care
i'm just gonna play b5 so now after
taking on a4
you're not hitting anything on this on
these fights rook d3 by magnus carlsen
a takes b3 rook takes b3 rook a4 from
lebron onion hitting this guy on e4
and i think magnus makes a mistake
probably it's just
better just to go f3 keeping the two
rooks
in the board because after c3 now rook
c4 from level and ronin
i think it's good for him to trade a
pair of rooks because the pawn can move
forward
the pawns can move forward easily right
so rook takes c2 rook takes c2
f3 from magnus carlsen and now
kinephate of course the kin has to be
an active fist in the end game as you
guys know in the middle game the kin
has to be castled in many occasions just
being safe but in an end game the king
has to
it's probably one of the most important
pieces right in this case gonna try to
help this
majority on the queen's side to succeed
so he leads two from magnus kini 7
kin h3 kini 6 rook d3
from carlson and kin rook c4 from
levon adronia okay all of this is fine
king g3 from magnus
kini 5 now black is aiming to go
f5 probably in some positions and magnus
carlsen decides
to activate this rook on the seventh
rank just targeting
f7 levon aaronian says you know what i
just don't care
i just play rook c3 just take on f7 i'm
gonna take on a3
and i got these two passers on the b
file and on the c
file who are running like a beast faster
than usain bolt these guys
so that's why magnus carlsen plays rook
a7
protecting a3 and level ironian protects
facundo
rk8 and i want to ask you what would you
play here with the black pieces
another important question because i'm
sure
you think in the same way that i was
thinking before checking this game
so it looks like we are now ready to
what
to push so c5 right
well d4 is a is a natural move and it's
a great move
but c5 looks very natural too but the
problem with c5 is rook d8
and now it's gonna be tough for black to
push these guys because
you cannot take on a3 because rook d5
and rook c5 probably
probably a draw and you cannot move the
rook
and next move is going to be rook d5 and
looks like
very tough for black to to push those
pawns on the queen side
so rook end games extremely difficult to
understand so
this is why lemonade went for king d6
jesse wants to go to c7
and then be happy and push the pawns on
the queen side
rook b3 was better according to the
engines but of course this is a very
strange move in this position
so kind d6 keen f4 from magnus now has
got some chances again he wants to play
g4 and then also try to use his majority
on the kingside
king c7 now there is no rook g8 so now
lebanon is ready
to push the c pawn carlitos is coming to
the action g4
king b7 attacking the rook rook g8 and
this has become
a crazy position because now black takes
on e3 magnus takes on g6
and then we come to the critical moment
where magnus carlsen could have made a
draw
but instead he just blundered very very
very badly in this position so
again one more question what do you play
here with the white pieces
you have lemon aronian in front of you
you have the chance to make a draw
against him or you
blunder and then you lose the game
nothing really bad happens
just go for the next game take a cup of
coffee
life is more important than a chest than
a than a gain of chess right
h5 h5 it's a move
but after b3 what do you play
e5 somebody's saying e5 well i can play
b3 anyway and after pawn takes f6 b2
and after f7 just b1
and f8 i just grab your queen if i want
with queen f1
that's right so the best move in this
position is rook g7 magnus carson took
on f6
and i'm going to show you what i think
he blundered or he didn't see
so rook g7 is just it's just a draw
because after king b6
rook g8 that's the idea just to go
to the background to give some checks so
for example rook a7 if you now try to
cover your king by rook b7
the king actually arrives kidney 3 and
then this is actually winning for white
so
black cannot do this but instead magnus
carson just took on f6
let's continue the the line so b3
rook f7 king b6 rook f8 from magnus
carson now
rook a7 fantastic move from level
naronia
so rb8 rook b7 and rook d8
and what do you play here with the black
pieces still not easy
another critical moment in the game
[Music]
so give me a move for black
c5 that's the best move in the position
b2 is actually a draw
so be careful because after rook d1 now
white stops is
this pawn so c5
you're gonna attack with the two passers
and now what i think
well i think magnus uh thought this was
a draft that this
following line kini 3 c4 and rook d1
probably
the first glance he's he thought that
kindy 2 was drawing
but after b2 king c2 now
there is a winning move for black did
you see this do you see this move
i think this is what he missed actually
come on beat magnus carlsen king c7 king
c7 doesn't win
because of rook d1 be careful
but instead just be one queen that's
right b1 queen
king takes b1 and king c7 check and then
black grabs the rook
so this is what i think that magnus
carlsen missed
c5 c4 and probably he realized at this
point that kindy two was not enough for
the draw so rook d1 was played
c3 from level narrow and now these two
passers
are very very close to promote rook b1
king c5 king d3 and now
magnus carlsen resigned you can actually
win with the black pieces with the move
king b4 or even c2 just wins as well
okay guys so this this has been all that
uh what i have prepared for this lecture
so we just checked
three fantastic compositions artistic
and games
and then this game between magnus
carlsen and levon and ronia
as i told you just a few minutes ago
i'll be streaming
uh on twitch uh in the saint louis
chess club channel in the two hours i
believe yes
so it's 11 00 p.m in madrid actually
from 11 p.m
to 1am so two hours of streaming so it
will be
very nice if you guys can come by and
then play some chess games and try and
try to crush me
and then publish it on the social media
beat this stupid grandmaster from spain
just plays like rubbish all the time
okay guys so hope you guys enjoyed this
lecture
so it's been a pleasure as usual see you
in the next show
take care